[Música]
es increíble el miedo que las personas
tenemos al fracaso a fracasar en los
estudios a fracasar en el amor a
fracasar en el trabajo en la vida en
general mi historia de hoy va acerca de
tres fracasos de mi vida en diferentes
etapas que quiero compartir con vosotros
no para fardar de ellos sino para que
aprendáis de ellos veáis que no me da
miedo compartir mis fracasos que
vosotros extraiga es la esencia de los
mismos y que ojalá tal vez después de la
charla de hoy vosotros mismos queráis
compartir con el resto de gente de aquí
mismo los vuestros propios así que os
presento las malas decisiones que me han
llevado aquí a día de hoy
y voy a empezar pues hace mucho tiempo
cuando yo era joven todavía cuando tenía
15 años y tenía que empezar a decidir
que quería estudiar si me han presentado
como matemático pero a mí lo que me
gustaba en aquellos tiempos era más la
medicina de hecho la medicina forense
habéis visto alguna vez una de estas
series de la tele donde pues sale el tío
en cuestión llega al forense
este ha muerto envenenado por cianuro
potásico le han cortado la arteria aorta
o lo echaron al mar y lo han comido en
127 peces por tres lados diferentes
pues sí me gustaban mucho estas cosas de
hecho tanto es así que cuando mi madre
venía decía juan hay pollo para la cena
pues yo decía pollo que está ahí
dame a mí el pollo cogió un cuchillo de
la cocina lo clavaba el pollo
desaparecía el pollo como habéis podido
observar y clavaba el cuchillo al pollo
lo abría en canal
y empezaba a sacar las tripas a mirar
los huesos decías ay mira tiene unos
huevitos dentro luego nos cocinamos poco
macabro verdad pues sí yo quería ser
médico forense y cuando llegó el momento
de empezar una carrera universitaria
justo el año antes tenía que elegir unas
asignaturas en bachillerato
una de esas asignaturas era biología
entonces ya me tenéis a mí con 17 años
eligiendo esa asignatura de biología
pero bueno entonces voy a clase de
biología y la profesora que tuve abría
el libro empezaba a releer arriba a la
izquierda en diagonal hasta abajo a la
derecha giraba y seguía leyendo y
leyendo y leyendo los aminoácidos el adn
los microorganismos yo no sé vosotros
pero a mí que me leyeran en clase no era
una forma muy divertida de aprender así
que tras dos semanas de cursar esta
asignatura en 2º bachillerato me fui al
jefe de estudios y le dije oye
no no quiero seguir haciendo biología a
mí es toda forma de aprender no me gusta
que otras asignaturas habría está a este
mismo horario a lo que el jefe de
estudios me dijo pues oye solo está la
ampliación de matemáticas pero si no
haces biología no te podrás examinar
para ser médico
vale cámbiame no vayas al médico
ya me tenéis cambiando la biología por
las matemáticas mi futuro se venía abajo
pero no no fue así
tomé la ampliación de matemáticas
descubrir lo que son los grupos anillos
cuerpos la topología estas cosas raras
que hablamos los matemáticos nunca
habéis habla con un matemático hablamos
de paján mentales que son increíbles
pues me encantaron
acabe el bachillerato hice la carrera de
matemáticas durante cinco años y a los
23 años me convertí en licenciado en
matemáticas con más de una decena de
matrículas de honor por tanto oye pude
volver a mi jefe de estudios y decirle
no no soy forense
soy matemático
justo aquí empezará la segunda de mis
historias estudiando matemáticas diréis
que es muy difícil no pues yo estudiaba
matemática por la mañana y por la tarde
como no tenía una mejor que hacer me iba
al conservatorio estudiar música
estudié piano claro matemáticas por la
mañana música por la tarde podréis
imaginar ya tenías poco tiempo libre no
si tenía un poco entonces no es de
extrañar que la mayoría de mi círculo de
amigos fuera o de un lado o de otro y
así fue pues como en el mismo
conservatorio pues conocí a una chica
empezamos a salir y diréis ah ahora
viene la historia de amor
bueno a medias recordáis esas
fantásticas notas que os he dicho pues
bueno la universidad me consiguieron una
beca para irme a parís a estudiar
tratamiento digital de imágenes que
básicamente es ahora esto que está tan
de moda no de vamos a quitarnos los
granos de la cara ponernos los brillitos
o los ojitos en los filtros de instagram
ahora lo tenemos bastante asumido en
2011 cuando esto empezaba a ser un boom
empresas que a lo mejor os suenan como
apple google o samsung buscaban a gente
que pudiera hacer estas cosas en sus
dispositivos y ese máster iba enfocado
precisamente hacer unas prácticas ahí y
si aprendí francés me fui a parís tenía
una beca todo pagado prácticas en esas
macro empresas y tuve la carrera más
impresionante que os podéis imaginar
porque en parís duren tres días
porque no supiera francés actitud para
que simulen un fecha de presentación
jones sí pero no es una prestación en
francés no os voy a torturar tanto si no
fue por el idioma fue por el amor tal
cual leonardo dicaprio cede esa puerta
al final de titanic a su querida rose m
a favor del amor que habían conseguido
en el titanic aunque todos sabemos que
esa puerta que había los dos a mí no me
jodáis ahí que habían los dos
pues yo dejé esa beca el máster en parís
un futuro profesional por volver a
mallorca por mi chica
cuando volví me fui a los profes que me
habían conseguido la beca lo siento pero
dejo el máster he vuelto
has rechazado la oportunidad de tu vida
es cerrar una puerta que nunca más se va
a abrir tenías el futuro garantizado
claro ante esa decisión sí que es verdad
que uno se asusta se acojona vivo o dice
eso
pero bueno qué haces cuando no tienes
nada mejor que hacer pues busque a ver
qué puedo hacer solo conocía el mundo
universitario así que me apunté a un
máster solo había plazas en 1 máster de
formación del profesorado bueno
no voy a analizar imágenes voy a hacerme
profe
me apunto al máster de profe y claro
vendiendo a estudiar grupos anillos
cuerpos topologías el teorema de la bola
peludas magníficos e teorema el
cuento
el máster de educación donde pues sí
hice un plan de estudios cómo se evalúa
cómo se pone un examen una guía docente
o una asignatura que me encantó cómo
hacer una grúa de papel de periódico y
grapas
todo proceso tiene que saber hacer una
grúa de papel de periódico y grapas os
puedo asegurar que más algo al culo
vamos cada día de mi vida casi casi
pues claro qué pasa cuando te cambias
así de una cosa para otra porque te
sobra el tiempo y qué hace cuando te
sobra el tiempo te va a salvar te tomas
unas cervezas que veis que pues algo de
efectos y que ha hecho pero yo empecé a
darle a darle vueltas al coco decir a
ver vas a dar clase a chavales de
instituto entre 13 14 15 años que hacen
los chavales del día con el móvil dale
que te pego el whatsapp
y por qué no aprovechamos eso para
enseñar utilizando su propio teléfono
móvil pues así fue como durante unos
meses me fue todo a aprender a crear
aplicaciones móviles y videojuegos para
que esta misma gente a la que yo iba a
dar clase pues pudiera aprovechar esas
aplicaciones para aprender en lugar de
la típica hoja de ejercicios que todos
habéis pasado por clase
pues bueno aprendí a hacer aplicaciones
con un curso de la universidad de
stanford y dije bueno pues vamos a
lanzarlas a la app store a ver si encima
vamos a ganar algo de pasta empiezo a
mirar por internet licencia anual cien
euros vale bueno como mucho perderé cien
euros en un año si no me comento raw
primer mes cinco euros a ver cinco por
doce meses serían 60 euros no llegó a
los 100 de que me ha costado la licencia
pero hoy sólo pierdo 40 segundo mes
veinte euros
esto ya mola más veinte euros ya me da
cubre los gastos de la licencia estampó
comprar una pizza al mes
el tercer mes los ingresos ya superaban
los 100 euros y conseguía lo que hoy en
día llamo mi primer trabajo remunerado
fui desarrollador de aplicaciones
móviles de videojuegos y me podéis
imaginar cuando volví a este profesor de
la universidad y le dije pues no no
analizo imágenes ni trabajo en apple y
samsung trabajo en el sofá de mi casa en
pijama con pijama pero casi haciendo
aplicaciones móviles y vídeo
y justo ahí empieza la tercera de las
historias
vosotros pensaréis hockey trabajo más
chulo tenías trabajabas desde casa
hacerlo entender esto a mis padres que
ya entrados en los 60 nunca han usado un
móvil no son muchos de tecnología y
demás decía turbo que eres un mago
trabajas en casa en pijama además pues
sí
por la tele un día estaba la tele
encendida lo típico que comes con la
tele de fondo no lo solemos hacer pero
justamente ese día acaba la tele
encendida y oigo algo así como play
space empresa desarrolladora de
videojuegos de social casino del parcbit
de aquí de mallorca recibe un millón y
medio de inversión para contratar a
desarrolladores de apps y videojuegos ya
tenéis a mi madre oye juan esto no estas
cosas raras que haces tú subes a la nube
esta es sí
pues haz un currículum edad buscando
trabajo hombre
vale decir que no tenéis el fin de
semana investigando cómo hacer un
currículum a veces tu currículum la
primera vez es muy
no es nada fácil buscas una foto en la
que salgas bien empiezas a rellenar
cuando ha rellenado media hoja dices
ya rente con alma gmt que hago cocino
bien tengo carné de coche juego al
bádminton no lo sé que hago macramé lo
que os dé la gana va a ir rellenando la
cuestión es rellenar hojas no es bueno
rellene ese currículum fin de semana me
presento un lunes a play space les dejo
el currículum encima de la mesa me iba
para el coche me llaman oye acabas dejar
un currículum que si mañana entrevista
de trabajo a las 9 cuestión
me presento al día siguiente un martes
entrevista de trabajo y al día siguiente
era contratado fijo con un sueldo de 20
mil euros que contigo que empieza pues
es la
por tanto mi segundo trabajo pagado
desarrollador de videojuegos y
aplicaciones en un estudio de
videojuegos ya no era en el sofá de casa
claro a partir de ahí mi primer trabajo
en una empresa aprendes a lidiar con el
equipo de marketing con el equipo de
desarrollo con el equipo de arte como
cada uno habla un idioma diferente yo
quiero este gráfico o yo quiero esta
línea de código optimizada o hazme un
banner para poner en facebook cats pero
a mí me vienen y me dicen oye ya sé que
te hemos contratado como desarrollador
de aplicaciones pero aquí pone que eres
matemático si matemático alguien que
resuelve problemas que no sabes que
tienes en un modo que no tienes ni
idea de cómo funciona también mago o
hechicero
y tú podrías hacer algo con estos datos
que hemos ido recabando en los últimos
años acerca de los usuarios
dame algunos meses entonces ya me tenéis
en 2012 los algoritmos que conocemos
como más in learning data science big
data en general no estaban tan
desarrollados como lo conocemos a día de
hoy entonces muchos de esos algoritmos
los tuve que investigar desarrollar
aprender de forma totalmente autodidacta
buscando por internet indagando y demás
la cuestión tres meses después la
empresa había facturado diez veces lo
que al inicio y habíamos podido crecer
de 12 empleados a más de 40 por tanto
oye yo considero que me lo ocurre y lo
hice muy bien
dicho esto
tenemos hoy le tenemos a juan gabriel
desarrollando estas cosas no estaban
publicadas por ningún lado yo mismo
empiezo a publicar y empresas de por el
mundo empiezan a hacerse eco de esto de
modo que me llaman de diferentes
congresos en inglaterra en parís berlín
para dar a conocer estas ideas empresas
que a lo mejor os suenan como square
enix desarrolladores de tomb raider o
final fantasy candy crush desarrollado
por king.com o assassin's creed
desarrollado por ubisoft son tres de las
empresas que llamaron a mi puerta para
que les fuera a contar de modo que tú te
ibas desde mallorca imaginaos un
mallorquín hecho y derecho se va de
viaje va a contar las ideas en su inglés
chapurreado y vuelve a mayor que así si
después de contar las ideas más feliz
que una perdiz y con un contrato de
trabajo con una de estas empresas
mi jefe pues
me dijo lo único que me podía decir si
te quedas con nosotros te igualamos su
sueldo
el sueldo de una de estas empresas aquí
en mallorca decime que vosotros no
firmaría jce pues sin firme y durante
tres años pase de ser el desarrollador
ese que había entrado por el anuncio de
la tele a dirigir el equipo de
analíticas y a ser director de producto
coordinando a esos 40 empleados debajo
de mí
claro esto os parece la leche pero llega
un momento que estas cosas te corroe por
dentro y dices realmente me valoran
ahora me y me podría haber pagado lo
mismo antes entonces me fue corriendo
por dentro y empiezo a pensar a pensar a
pensar me quiero ir así que me voy a mi
referido hoy me voy quién te ha hecho
una oferta ahora no nadie me ha hecho
una oferta así que escogí las cosas y me
picaron me voy
donde vais que no ha trabajado
no sé contra el fracaso hace falta a
lado lo bueno no
si me fui y qué pasó pues que empecé a
pensar quiero enseñar al resto del mundo
de esto que yo he aprendido voy a crear
cursos online
así fue como creé mi primer curso curso
de desarrollo de apps para ellos 9 ya en
2015 las prensas se empezó a hacer eco
un mallorquín creando cursos online en
una plataforma donde sólo había cursos
en inglés pues si se escribieron notas
de prensa empecé a ser llamado a la
radio a ser llamado en los periódicos y
parecía que aquello tenía futuro de
hecho os imagináis la primera vez que
una persona paga diez euros puede
escucharme es como vosotros estáis
escuchando de aquí pero online por todo
el mundo me fui paseando por mallorca
por todas las ferias de emprendimiento
los parkings de la universidad los
parkings del parc bit repartiendo flyers
regalando mis cursos me importaba poco
el dinero quería que la gente empezara a
hacerse con estas cosas esto llegó a
noticias interesantes y a partir de ahí
cogiendo el feedback de la gente yo
mismo empecé a decir vale esta gente
quiere desarrollo de aplicaciones
también de videojuegos más recientemente
big data machine learning matemáticas
para videojuegos cosas de este estilo
pues fui aprendiendo de todo eso y fui
creando un portfolio como os ha contado
antes
de 50 cursos en la actualidad con 86 mil
estudiantes claro esto ya os parecerá
guau
estás en una nube sí pero no contento
con mi trayectoria fue llamado por
platts y otra empresa de cursos online
en este caso en latinoamérica para
visitar diferentes veces latinoamérica
para grabar cursos especialmente para
ellos en un estudio fantástico o incluso
ser nombrado instructor oficial de unity
el motor de videojuegos para viajar por
todo el mundo enseñando a estudios de
videojuegos como team seventeen los
creadores de los bornes o ubisoft mismo
creadores de los assassins creed
entonces os podéis imaginar esto sólo
podía ir a más y diréis guau ya está
acaba de una vez no todavía fue mejor
porque os imagináis la vez que suena mi
teléfono y me dicen oye juan gabriel no
nos conoces somos de una universidad de
bolivia y utilizamos tus cursos para
enseñar a nuestros estudiantes
desarrollo de videojuegos te importaría
venir unos días y les cuentas todo esto
qué haces vacaciones pagadas en bolivia
anda que no nos vamos todos pues si me
fui a bolivia tiene un auditorio de
gente no me cupo la gente
tuve que repetirla al día siguiente la
gente subiéndose al escenario profesor
déjeme hacerme una foto firme un
autógrafo ostia que soy un profeta una
estrella de rock está bien entonces es
magnífico la sensación y fijaros que
había dejado un puesto de trabajo donde
ganaba más que cualquier otra persona
ganaba más que mis padres o sea era un
cambio bastante drástico lo último pues
lo último fue ser llamado a san
francisco a dar una conferencia en you
de mí o ser invitado a facebook oa
google para conocer sus instalaciones y
que se hicieran eco de mi trabajo pero
podría haberme quedado en el camino así
que sí quiero que os llevéis algo es que
en un momento dado podría haberme
quedado con biología en lugar de pasar
por matemáticas
podría haberme quedado en parís en lugar
de volver por una chica o podría haberme
quedado con el sueldo de play space en
lugar de emprender desde cero el mundo
de la enseñanza online
así que si la población o mis amigos me
decían que me equivocaba que no tomara
esas decisiones que seguir la línea que
debería haber seguido era lo correcto
pero si me equivocado y me siento muy
orgulloso de mi error así que si tenéis
algún error que valga la pena compartir
hacedlo porque probablemente de los
errores que cometemos hoy os sentiréis
muy orgullosos mañana gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]